(glass breaking)
(rock music playing)
- [Vin] I remember saying, c'mon,
Dom can't just lift up this car.
I've seen people look
at me like I was crazy,
like of course you can.
It's technically possible.
If anyone can do it, it's Dom.
And I'm thinking, oh my god,
the belief that you all have
in Dom is just profound.
It was so enticing because it
was so much wish fulfillment.
God, we were asked to fly.
- Dom, cars don't fly.
- [Vin] And it was that
moment where we realized,
Fast and Furious didn't need
to be restricted in any way.
We were allowed these outrageous moments
and flying through the air
from building to building
was playing to that.
It was one of those answers to the riddle,
how do we one up the
spectacle of each film.
Traditionally, we always tried to take
a practical approach first.
The first film, we went to
race car driving school.
As we continued making a film,
it was more important for us
to go to stunt driving school.
So we'll take practical run.
But something as outrageous as that, ah.
If you wanna know if Paul
and I drove from one building
to the next, as much as
I'd like to say, maybe,
it's pretty obvious that might
not have been the smartest
thing for us to do.
What's funny is if you
talk to us back then,
we'd be willing to do anything.
Without taking away the
magic of movie making,
thank god that that was in 2014
and we were able to use CGI
the way we did.
And you can learn as much as you want
when it's actually shoot day,
and the pyrotechnics are
launching fireballs in the air
and you're driving through smoke,
it's always a dangerous thing.
I don't think the world
realized how much risk
one has to consider when doing
some of those action sequences with cars.
Fortunately, we were safe.
It's been so many great stunts,
I say this is in the top five.
My first reaction was giddy.
I was like holy shit, we pulled it off.
(Vin laughing)
I was kinda blown away.
When you're sitting in that
theater and you see that scene,
the first thing that reacts
is the inner child in you
and that's a testament
to an iconic moment.
After the first film, Paul
Walker and I were at the airport
and we're just sitting on the floor,
people were walking over us
and he looked over at me
and said take all this in
because this will be our
last moment of anonymity.
He knew that we struck a
chord in the public somehow.
It's a big part of my life.
Both the happy times and
the severe melancholy
that has come with this whole franchise.
But I'm proud of every
moment and every frame
and everybody that's contributed
to this record breaking saga.